starwars nothing booth stunts you know
the song you know the drill you know the
kick holy [ __ ] we have a trailer alright
so he just got out of the last Jedi
panel and we figured there was gonna be
a trailer for the last Jedi and they
tease for a little bit and then the
Brian Johnson was like of course is a
trailer so now I'm gonna talk about
first thing I'm gonna talk about in
first of all sorry about the quality I'm
literally filming this on my phone if
you're gonna watch the trailer and see a
panel of Star Wars people you're gonna
have to take a hit and quality just is
what it is timing first thing they
revealed is the poster first it's like
Oh ray holding the blinds ever the
backside like faces spaces of creepy
looking people to be honest with it I
would never allow my 16 year old
daughter today that dude and I would
never allow my 2 year old daughter to be
babysat by that day so now ray is going
to get trains are in the trailer it
starts out it turns a light you're like
what am I looking at stars I don't know
if that's a rock and then ray drops to
the ground she's panting and you're like
were you training were you exercising
were you doing cardio or did you have a
force vision probably a force vision it
looks like she saw some pretty heavy
[ __ ] and in the trailer you hear Luke go
breathe just breathe what did you see
just like the light the dark she's
seeing both I feel like this is gonna be
a very complex movies not just gonna be
light side good dark side bad looks like
it's gonna be layers to it I really like
that then it shows her training on our
cliff somewhere
Luke's there it looks like that's a
statue of where you trade in for heart
containers and Legend of Zelda breath of
the wilds that Yoda is sitting on the
top but people have asked if it is I
don't I don't have the answer I'm gonna
pop the sizing and theorizing with the
resin you guys there shows some action
happening it shows these ships like
you're paving lines into the sand like
they're gonna run a marathon or
something like all right start line
finish line let's make it let's make a
baseball field but but going after what
looks like 8080 blockers phasma's back
just really sweet trash compacter did
not kill her that's good hopefully she
has the time to shine
looks like she might because she's
strolling into what looks like a lot of
death it's just kinda ready holds up his
lightsaber you see red in his eyes I
don't know if that's red because he's
that you know it's like evil sick person
red or not sick I guess cousin Jetta it
looks like they might be going away but
he does have his wonky lightsaber I
didn't want him to have a clean one I
wanted him to have a janky little wonky
lightsaber because I think that shows a
cool finish it's it's a nice touch to a
red lightsaber I wonder what the red in
his eyes is because there was a picture
I couldn't get a good picture of it but
there was
picture of a blue it was phasma kylo Ren
and Huck's kylo Ren it was kind of a
profile of him and his face was really
pale he had a scar and his eyes straight
up look too yellow if you look at we
were all our yellow eyes right I'm not
making that [ __ ] up we all agree he
looked like he had yellow eyes in that
picture a poster whatever that was but
kylo Ren with no mask with a star pale
face with yellow eyes i pre-ordered that
Auto and design and then the trailer
ends with Luke Skywalker saying
something to the effect of I know one
truth it's time for the Jedi you're like
to rise he's like to end and then he
shows the dial nose like [ __ ] and it
goes along with what Daisy Ridley was
saying in that pound she was like
sometimes you meet your heroes and
they're not who you think they're gonna
be so I feel like reg does this again me
theorizing the [ __ ] out of it I feel
like reg ghosts are like Luke's gonna
teach me to be a Jedi I'm gonna be a
Jedi he's like no it's it's not like
that they even talked about like the
light side dark side there's so much
more doing it for nothing else
Luke's figured it out like balancing the
forces balance within light side and
dark side you're going to have both and
maybe that's not what she wants maybe
she wants to be a certain way and maybe
I don't know snow or kylo Ren come along
if you like I can show you you know you
want power I can give you that why not
power sponge that's totally what you
want maybe turn her back I don't know
I'd really love that last line I feel
like in the end of this trilogy there
are going to be no more SIF
no more Jeff there's already no more SIF
that we know of but no more Jedi also
it's just light side and dark side is so
much bigger than the religions that use
and manipulate it only speaking you're
like this does feel different than the
force awakens I think people are going
to a dark place what can I say it's just
what I feel like but it was a great
trailer great first trailer a walk now
they're super happy and now I make a
video for you guys in the greatest
quality video ever because that's how I
roll with you suck again the next one
when I get back home
don't worry green screens red
backgrounds so I want to know what you
guys think about it so the trailer for
Star Wars the last Jedi we have it what
did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]